Después de tres días completos de
deliberación del Jurado se ha llegado a
un veredicto
Stuart Road el fundador de la milicia de
extrema derecha of keepers ha sido
declarado culpable de Conspiración
sediciosa en relación con el asalto del
6 de enero en el Capitolio de Estados
Unidos
estamos decepcionados con El veredicto
de culpabilidad creemos que hemos
presentado un caso que ha demostrado
mediante pruebas y testimonios que el
señor roads no cometió el delito de
Conspiración sediciosa
el cargo de Conspiración es ediciosa
raramente utilizado es un estatuto de la
época de la guerra civil Esta es su
primera aplicación en casi 3 décadas y
junto a roads otro acusado también fue
declarado culpable por el cargo el
juicio de casi dos meses se mostraron
los esfuerzos del grupo por mantener a
Donald Trump en la casa blanca a toda
Costa y comenzó después de las
elecciones de 2020 tras el asalto de Los
partidarios de Trump al congreso para
interrumpir la certificación de la
elección de Joe biden a pesar de no
entrar en el Capitolio los fiscales
afirman que actuó como general de
batalla y mostraron al Jurado sus
mensajes de texto vídeos incluyendo una
grabación con roads diciendo que quería
colgar a la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi El veredicto
es una importante Victoria para el
departamento de justicia de Estados
Unidos que ya tiene acerca de 900
personas detenidas en todos los estados
por participar en el asalto algo que
puede allanar el camino para otras
condenas